so guys you know that saying that we
need to make an announcement about do
you know what I'm talking about Wyatt no
okay you know what's what our big thing
is for our family right like our big
announcement do you know what it is
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay as
mom and I have a big announcement to
make
but if you thought that I was going to
sit here and make the announcement
myself you're sorely mistaken because my
family is far too extra for that I let
the kids plan our big announcement all
by themselves don't be that person who
skips to the end and writes in the
comments what the announcement is my
kids worked hard on this they put their
heart and souls into this this is
something they planned by themselves so
just just don't do that to them
here's what happened you guys get to
plan the announcement mmm all by
yourselves no not you you decide where
we take the picture you decide what the
theme is you decide what props we hold
if we're holding anything and you know
if you want to do the letter board you
can write whatever you want on the
letter board do you want to I'm seeing
both of you can
would be let's give me a value oh gosh
are you up for it
yeah are you up for it yeah okay go in
your room and start thinking about it
okay bye
sweet now we can watch TV yeah so I was
really curious to see what they would
choose okay what okay you can wear that
I have another question where are we
going to take these photos
Batsy at BuzzFeed really my kids love to
come to BuzzFeed I think they were
really excited to have like free reign
over the canteen in there since we're
shooting on a weekend today's a day it's
photo shoot day I look like I'm going to
a holiday party or something looks good
Wow so day of shoot we packed up all of
our clothes and we had to stop to get
some props on the way we're gonna stop
for props the boys have some very
particular props they stopped the more
props my kids shout it out that they
wanted in the shoot the more I realized
they just wanted food that I don't buy
for them so we ended up with a lot of
junk food a lot of treats cookies
Cheetos takis family size because that's
apparently necessary for this photo and
pizza we're here at BuzzFeed we got in
they're already drinking their props now
our photographer for this shoot is a
person who's very special to me her name
is G Andhra Chandra his shots mine and
Matt's engagement session now she shot
our wedding and so it's only fitting
that she's here there's nobody else who
I would want shooting something like
yeah so she got started on my makeup the
boys chose blue for my eyeshadow color
and like a very bright pinky red for the
lips so I was a little bit nervous
because that just gives me major beauty
pageant vibes and so while I was getting
my makeup done everybody else got
dressed okay this is my finished look
the boys picked the colors Deandra I
don't even know if you're in there she
is she made it look decent
I don't understand anything that they
chose Jackson chose a white dress from
my closet to wear which is just so not
him okay he's wearing masks and a wand
barely covered every inch of Matt's face
for this any of you out there who have
tried to take family photos with like
over three people you know the struggle
of having everybody looking at the
camera and not blinking and not making a
stupid face
so I was actually fine with having one
person in a full mask because that means
I only have to think about three people
looking at the camera why it's outfit
choice did not surprise me at all
whatsoever he is the most he wore the
most he wanted to be a 1920s paperboy
and he was what mom on instagram doesn't
own a letter board so we got a letter
board and we let the kids write out what
the letter board was going to say why is
holding a bag of chips
him and you're holding a bag of chips
and a Slurpee I at this point I didn't
think that the announcement would even
make sense I didn't think that it would
come across in the photo at all what we
were actually trying to announce because
it was just such a cluster but that's
kind of how our family is overall it was
really surprising how well-behaved they
were maybe it's because I let them
choose every part of it but it was the
most seamless family photo shoot I think
we've ever had so that's the key out
there for any parents watching let your
kids pick the photo shoot and the
picture might look very weird but they
will be smiling and so without further
ado here's the big announcement if it
wasn't abundantly clear in the photo
there is one more butt face on the way
at the time of this video I am almost
six months the baby is due at the end of
the year
the boys are so excited they are so
excited to have a little brother I'm
terrified I'm excited I know that I was
very open about having a miscarriage I
we weren't trying we weren't putting
pressure on it it was something I was
actively trying to you know not stress
about and obsess over and I guess that
was just the time that it needed to
happen
so right now I've nothing but gratitude
for what has happened for us and that
everything is healthy everything is good
I can finally relax a little bit and
just enjoy it so I could not be more
excited to share this with you stay
tuned for more episode leave anything in
the comments that you've wanted to know
about pregnancy or anything you really
wish you could see that we're
experiencing right now because I'm
really this is new territory for me guys
because trip like finally truly you
could say that I'm actually a mom and
progress so if you please excuse me I
have to pee I've been holding it this
whole time I've been move get out of my
way